thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of careful boys today we
have Mr Jason Cheney with us
[Applause]
so uh we also have Ken sitting in on
we're hearing this hey what's up
[Applause]
slightly uneasy that's because For the
first time in history Anthony's on that
side of the table that's not true oh
we've I've sat next to you before really
on that side
while the cameras were on for sure how
did we all match dude your black shirt
oh [ __ ] gray sweaters and out of all the
days like this wasn't even planned you
know why Jason Cheney said earlier
during lunch he says we're all in the
same wavelength that's what that's not
what I said that's what he said I didn't
say that you didn't say that I said this
is what this is it's just we're not on
this this is what this is you don't
think we're in the same way what does
that even mean
you see this hostility this is what I
mean I feel like we're on the same wave
like I take that it does seem like the
way by we're not on the same wavelength
are you are you in a higher frequency or
lower frequency no I'm in a frequency
just like a different frequency it
doesn't matter yeah but it always it
only goes high or low though yeah no yes
it does yes there's Lo-Fi and high five
I'm in the universe bro it's like dice
there's only high or low yup okay really
say okay that's fine
I just feel like we're not on the same
frequency what YouTube I'm on [ __ ] a
FM radio you guys are on AM radio you
said you predicted that Joe would wear
this today no I didn't so actually I got
this uh as a gift from my mom like a few
weeks ago for my birthday and then I was
like you know what I'm just gonna wear
this today and then he ended up wearing
his because I knew he had one I was like
oh nice you know happy birthday look at
Joe man yeah yeah the synchronization of
this room is kind of weird though
because like a lot of the times we don't
know that we're assigned next to these
seatings right yeah and then we'll be
color coded or like we'll match or like
it'll be like one day I'm wearing like
green and pink and then the the person
next to me is wearing green and pink but
like from top to bottom like Swap and
we're just like what the [ __ ] can I say
something though what there's always a
good shot you're gonna wear kimono
though
say something what um there's also a
good shot it feels like we're matching
because nothing else in here matches
there's only something you both have
gray hoodies I know that that's like
something you both have black shirts my
washing machines specifically black
shirts with smiley faces oh my god wow
that's creepy you don't want to do
better you guys are all wearing black
pants get the [ __ ] out of here
that's gray this is gray but that's been
happening at JK news like forever yeah
that's really cool man even when David
used to always be here I mean there's
only so many like colors colors to wear
and like yeah but today
but this like come on dude
oh I think it's not Joe it's definitely
not Joe it's not a joke but I like that
you're wearing a kimono thank you
question of the day now that we've all
felt like we're paired up and everything
I wanted to know what is the loneliest
you've ever felt oh bro right now why
because I'm single you feel do I
honestly feel lonely right now yeah all
the time but it's not like a bad thing
it's like one of those things where you
can't help what you feel it's like oh I
got I'm working you know I I go to the
gym I do everything I have hobbies I
have friends but then there's always
that time where you're like oh but I'm
single so it's like
because when everything settles down
it's just you huh I felt alone but not
lonely
oh you've never felt that's really nice
uh sometimes
but in for most of my recent life no
what can I ask you what's the what's
like a couple people that you feel that
you're most connected with because to
feel not lonely I feel like you need to
have somebody that you feel like you're
really connected with yeah I think uh
I just feel like I have a really tight
closeness with my family and friends
that I don't need them around all the
time even though I'm extroverted like I
I like I really like the company of
people but when kovid happened during
lockdown I was by myself for like a
month and the two human interactions
that I had was one one time my buddy
came to drop off cheesecake and then the
other one
um
I think so yeah one of my other friends
came by to drop something off at the
door so for the whole month all of my
interactions was like Zoom phone calls
and stuff like that
and I didn't even notice it
yeah so so I didn't maybe because all
day like we were doing like me and Steve
we were doing those lives together we
were like I was always like I was on the
phone like chatting with people so like
I was stimulated
like socially but if you're not would
you still feel fulfilled because of the
connections that you know that you have
what do you mean by that like because
you sometimes you know sometimes you
just go on the phone and talk to people
and then you're like oh I'm connecting
with somebody but even though they might
not be your close friend but if you
don't talk to anybody would you still
feel like oh I I'm alone but I don't
feel lonely because you know that they
still love you and yeah yeah like my
family like my friends like all this
stuff right so I don't you know how like
some people they need to always check in
and be like Oh and then when you don't
talk to them for a while they're like
are we still friends and [ __ ] I don't
have that like all of my friendships
it's like it's always in the uh in the
moment we're like there but I could not
talk to you guys for like months and
then when we see each other we'll start
off where we left off
how many people do you have like that
like a handful like I would say aside
from my my um
aside from Hannah I'm with her like
every single day except for when I'm in
LA right but uh everybody outside of
that even my mom in a whatever all of my
relationships are like that wow so it
once like like let's say like me and Ken
like we lived with each other for like
over five years we can tell something
like that something like that we've been
roommates we've been friends for a long
time
day but I feel like I have that I have
that relationship with him where like
once I think I feel like uh once you
have that security of friendship and
whatever like I could not talk maybe for
like months and then we can see each
other and like
start where we left off yeah give each
other hugs yeah those are the best
friendships by the way I think so I
think most of my friends like healthy
space yeah you know you're not always
like do you feel like that too I think
in a way I do yeah I know what I think
uh
I mean I'm I think I'm the type of
friend where you don't have to like
check in a lot and if I see you again
whether it's like a year or a day like
I'm gonna I'll still remember everything
yeah I'm pretty good with that what
about you that's really nice
do you have that
um like I have one person that's like
that but I've just met recently oh yeah
that's that's really nice yeah most of
your friends like you're always hanging
out talking no I don't I don't really
have friends besides my wife and my
wife's sister I love them hello yeah
dude we're your friends yeah hi is that
what you mean wavelength busy doing
orgies
do all the logistics and then when
you're there you got to put the penis
inside all the [ __ ] you know there's
a there's a really a really crazy story
I can tell you guys about it uh there's
um I got a glimpse of like what true
loneliness like really is and it was
crazy
uh it was in 2012 I had done a show in
Adelaide in Australia the stage we were
on it was for this music festival where
the stage was very uh it was very short
so it didn't go very far and there were
these like speaker monitors out in the
way and I got to do the same set every
day that we do this show and I didn't
have enough room to do this flip so I
got self-conscious and then I landed and
hit the back of my head and then it felt
like this was my second concussion I
ever had and it felt like teleportation
like I hit my head oh my God next thing
I know I'm in the wings standing here
watching the stage and then my friends
my friends here and he goes hey are you
okay and then right when I I teleported
again to the green room and I'm sitting
there and there's like 10 people around
me and they're like yo are you okay like
it's that fast and then uh once it start
started subsiding and I could kind of uh
tell where I was I'm in a hotel room
with some guy that I don't know and he's
like hey uh I'm here to just make sure
that you don't fall asleep oh my God so
what happened is um we were doing these
shows so quickly in succession that they
had to move on to Perth and they
couldn't put me on the plane because
they were like if your brain's swelling
you got to just stay grounded and then
so they paid uh one of the event staff
guys to just go to my hotel and then
just sit there and just stare at me
basically and talk to me and that was
the fourth thing I remembered in that
row so I'm just sitting here in a room
with a dude I've never seen in my life
and he's just like how do you feel like
well do you want to watch music videos
what do you want to do just like to hang
out with me so I don't like knock out
and then never wake up and all this is
like I'm trying to process this like in
the moment so then we're sitting there
and I like things started to get back to
normal speed again and I'm sitting in
this room we're watching go ta [ __ ]
what's that song Somebody that I used to
know about and I just I'm just watching
it and I'm just like in the haze and
then I'm thinking [ __ ] I gotta I got a
concussion and everybody left and I'm
gonna have to meet them later in the
next city uh I should tell my girlfriend
like what happened so then I I go go to
the um I'm like yo I'm gonna go to the
computer so I go to the computer room in
this hotel and then I I go on a Gmail to
like try to email her or something
because back then you I could just text
and then I was like uh going through my
emails what the [ __ ] my password like
I didn't even remember my password so
it's like like that one Memento like it
is and then I and then I um and then I I
remembered it finally and I went to my
email and I went I don't even have a
girlfriend
I was single and I thought I had a
girlfriend and I went holy [ __ ] like
what is my where what's my life you
thought you had a girlfriend by reflex
and I was I realized I was actually
single and there was nobody I was
thinking of nobody and then at that
moment is when it really hit that I'm
like I'm completely alone like there's
nobody here with me I don't even know
how to communicate with anybody I think
all I can do is sit here and just be
dizzy yeah and that was the except for
the one guy in the room that's like
hello
I'll hang with you I'm gonna have
somebody to call no I didn't I just I
just was like they had left a message
saying that because they had to go right
we would go back to that I know yeah so
then I was just like okay I'll meet them
later I'll meet them later and then I
just remembered that was the moment
where like I never felt that lonely
that's a crazy loneliness yeah and it's
almost like a simulation of loneliness
where it's not truly you're not truly
alone but the feeling is enough and I
didn't go to hospital there or what
happened when I got to Perth yeah they
had a doctor check me out but the crazy
thing is that what I learned from that
is like
there's people that feel that without
that even happening like without a
concussion they just feel this [ __ ]
at home yeah all the time and it was
like I was like holy [ __ ] and that gave
me a lot of empathy for like people that
go through actual loans depression
because I'm like for me that was like a
chemical imbalance kind of loneliness
but jeez yeah can I say a thing
I just want to make sure I could say the
thing don't say whatever you want thank
you for asking yourself you're too
polite sometimes I I would I like to be
polite I know I try to be
can I do anything
or would you I don't know if you guys
feel this but sometimes maybe it's just
um sometimes people I would like people
to see me but that's why I was doing the
wavelength thing like talking about
wavelength a lot of the times I don't
feel like people understand me like not
like communication I try to be but like
see the person that I am and um because
sometimes with relationships you build
the Relationships by like explaining to
other people how you are and why you do
the things you do and then they started
to understand you so that when you
communicate they go oh this is this
person that's why he's reacting this way
but there's only like one person that
see me that way but we don't talk
anymore but that's really because you
know how when you build a relationship
like that with somebody and they
understand you that's a nice friendship
but then you're like
oh man like my wife like I this is so
cool that if you build a relationship
that people could understand you so well
this is impossible every day I woke up
like that but once I met this person I'm
like how can somebody see me like this
without building it like they just
connect oh it just clicks yeah it just
clicks but but it feels [ __ ] up when
you can't talk to that person and then
so every time you're like because I
don't know doing stand-up
um is like you know you just want a
failed scene and feel the feel
understood you know all the time and um
and I feel like I feel like that's a
little bit lonely too like to always
want to be like hey see me it is go
ahead can I ask something
[Laughter]
depending on what it is
who is this person that you it was a
friend that uh that I had a orgy with
you remember
[Laughter]
the party
for men I thought I had orgy I'm so
lonely
[Laughter]
but that's crazy but yeah but I feel
like sometimes it's like a yeah I don't
know how to dodge your question I don't
know how to do that
I don't know how to do it sometimes I
don't know how to when you connect with
somebody and then oh yeah like you do
feel like a lot of people don't
understand you I feel but I don't I
don't feel like because back to the
wavelength thing the loneliness thing
sometimes I feel like that here because
you guys are so you guys are on the same
wavelength like I know you said it takes
a while but it's just a person too just
as how you are as a person you guys all
are on like the same wave and you could
you think I'm on the same wave with
these fools
but the thing is you do like crazy like
act out things too and then it's like
but it's a fun thing and it matches you
know what I mean it complements
everything everybody comes with it
because he said the precedent can I say
something because we're all in the same
wavelength
it's a good time why do you feel like
we're not on the same wavelength you
guys are it's not with you no because I
don't get I'd like because some you guys
know a lot about the culture and the
culture like movie or uh movie or music
references and also like uh and also
it's just the way you guys do
comedy together it's very like Sim like
a and you guys had can I finish my thing
I'm just I'm just waiting I'm Gonna
Stand by this is waiting this is like
putting up you're calling me when you're
ready yeah all right okay put your hand
down sorry
relax man
that's all though but that's how I feel
but but um but that's normal for a
newcomer [ __ ] no that not oh not always
so you don't think some people come in
here guys see Rose's hand first yeah
yeah but
no I forgot I was gonna say yeah oh no
there was a [ __ ]
you should not make it up he's Konya now
that's a lot of pressure I know we are
matching can I take the Baton yeah go
ahead take it but it does feel lonely
when you don't connect with somebody
you're making yourself I'm gonna
Gaslight your ass a little bit yeah
you're making yourself feel lonely
because we accept you we like you we
think that you Vibe that's why you keep
getting invited that's why so the rest
of us feel that you are joining in but
it's in your own head that you feel that
you're not joining enough okay but
objectively speaking I'm I don't do the
same no no you're a stand-up comedian
which is fine no but no in here but it
doesn't matter just as a human like when
we objectively speaking I don't know how
to do the same thing to you guys you're
constantly just building this wall
between us 100 and that's my point as a
construction Builder it's like you keep
putting you keep putting these metrics
in front Okay really weird and
uncomparable you know okay because we've
also spent how many hours you think
we've spent in the room together so many
hours so many [ __ ] hours but you know
what I think would would turn it around
for you is if we all went and
experienced something new for the first
time you want to make up well we've all
experienced we've all done that without
you he said new I mean like if he went
like if you did an adventure with us and
we all were the we're doing something
for the first time I think then you
would see oh we actually are in the same
way like because maybe we'll talk about
some things you're not as familiar with
but if we were newly dropped into the
same experience I think you would go oh
[ __ ] we're kind of digesting this very
similar 100 that that's interesting but
that's interesting you're about to shut
it down I caught myself I caught myself
has he seen uh uh uh old enough for
kisses oh the show I'm talking about I'm
not on the same way you just made me
feel what I felt that has nothing to do
inside jokes giving you information see
you're rejecting it before it even gets
past you and that hurts my feelings yeah
that's how I feel too I can't even look
at you with other people too he is
creating a wall between us no not just
you China
are you too shy to get really you're
treating us like we're Mongolians and
you're a big bad China making this big
[ __ ] wall and we just want to hang
out dude yeah but with other people too
is the thing like with other people I
just don't feel like oh man people do
you mean everybody like uh or Comics you
know any co-workers you know anything
yeah go ahead oh do you feel like that
at parties too like when you like throw
yourselves into like scenarios where you
just don't know anyone the most anxious
thing that's the most dangerous parties
yeah like any any place I feel like a
lot of people could relate to that
though yeah that's what I'm saying I
feel like a lot of people do feel the
way I feel and you guys just a bunch of
[ __ ] bullies yeah man internet
bullies
but I think that's normal I think you're
supposed to if it's a new crowd or
you're supposed to walk into the
situation
expecting that this is going to be like
we're how do you gauge this like where
do I stand with you like I don't like
people are figuring that out that's
normal right that's normal and then to
feel left out is normal when you're when
they these guys known each other for so
many years and you come in but then also
I feel like some people are more
thinking about themselves most people
are thinking about themselves and they
think about you so then I can walk into
that situation knowing that everybody
here is too busy thinking about how can
I impress this person how can I do that
that they're not worrying about me so I
could come in and I can laugh and just
enjoy I think it was just another thing
too like I I just give an example
because I was I'm just giving example in
here but outside too as well I think
because my mind I just like maybe I like
too many like too deep of a thing I'm
like
I like I'm like because if you have a
couple friends that you're like oh I
connect I know what you're saying really
well you like us we like you too dude a
lot that's what you're saying you're
like you're nervous because you really
like us and you want us to break down
the wall that you're building
I see
Anthony gets it dude
he's holding your hand through the whole
thing wow he's making you see God right
now he wants to impress us dude we we
are impressed by it doesn't feel good
enough for us or or most people or a lot
of people is the thing but then that's
something that you're saying you'll feel
that no matter where you are huh yeah
that's what I'm saying it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
he's trying to get on the wavelength
he's part of the crew dude you're
surfing bro I like it wow that's cool it
means that no matter how much we can go
hey dude you fit right now you're
awesome yeah yeah there's a skepticism
built in because
[Music]
dude I [ __ ] gave you the heart
yeah I can understand that but I think I
feel like you know we've all felt like a
little bit no you haven't you don't
understand some of us
here's the wall Hit It
come on hit the wall
love a bulldozer when I first came on
the show I didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on I didn't I just said not even
here yeah as a human being but that's
everywhere you go like what Joe said
you've everyone feels like do you think
people actually connect and understand
me
not the way if you say it like that it's
a good example but okay but you not have
a person that you like this person gets
me yes that's what I'm saying people who
get me yeah
um but I don't expect people to get me
yeah I think that's fine yeah yeah but
then how nice is it to those people yeah
yeah and I just wish I could have that
all the time right you gotta build it
yeah you gotta that's what I'm saying
when you like build it it's not the same
huh nothing not titogi I heard tetaki
you heard Ted talky you want to try
something even though we're totally out
of time now who cares watch this watch
this watch come sit over here real quick
and then if I sit there you're gonna
feel weird Energy number one no so much
of the room so much of the room's energy
has to come this way and then especially
with your guests when I was the first to
guess I was like also always nervous and
thinking about stuff when you sit
farther out you get to just hop in when
it's convenient I think you were
[ __ ] honestly this is the best time
I'm such a regular when you sit over
there oh my God I feel the wall I feel
my own walls
all right you know what let's add it
this way we're gonna initiate you now
yeah so you'll never feel left out again
give bring that over there just show it
okay it's not even just here just just
watch it
this guy doesn't do effort to like build
relationships with people I do go ahead
play it there right this is Clint
Eastwood yeah check it out
12.
13.
do it shut the [ __ ] up
it says give me more this is to give me
more remix oh that's [ __ ] crazy right
did you hear what you said though I
don't give a [ __ ] what she said she was
gonna be 13 in September
crazy right
shout out Steve Green
and uh he's kind of in the club now
that's not normal though
how do you how does that make you feel
well that that's crazy that's inside a
movie would you say that's [ __ ] up
no that's normal oh I'm on the wave life
now
I volleyed it up for you you're supposed
to knock it out the park and say no
that's [ __ ] weird that's not [ __ ]
up I'm on the wavelength now
no that's not the wavelength we don't we
don't like that oh oops